[inaudible].
All right,
well I'm talking today with Dr. James
Lindsey,
Dr Peter Boghossian,
and Dr Helen pluck roads and they're all
famous or infamous depending on your
perspective as the authors of a series
of hoax articles that were published in
what purport to be academic journals in
the last year following up work done by
socal back.
How long ago was that?
Now it's gotta be like 25 years now.
Right,
right.
So we've all assumed or you've all
assumed that the situation hasn't
improved.
So the first thing I'm going to do,
we're going to have an extended
discussion about these articles and
about the motivation for producing them
and then the necessity for that,
the morality of that at the aftermath
and all of that in.
The first thing I'm going to do is have
each of you introduce yourself and then
we'll launch right into a discussion of,
let's call it the scandal.
Dr. Lindsey.
Yeah.
Good to be here.
So I have a background in mathematics
and physics.
My Phds in math.
I left academia in 2010 and had been
studying,
uh,
mostly religious and moral philosophy
and psychology since,
and then got wrapped up in this idea.
I kind of was the,
I guess,
epicenter of the project.
I did all the submissions and managed
all the emails and all of that.
And then Peter and Ellen,
uh,
filled in all of my weaknesses.
And so we spent,
you know,
an 18,
about 18 months working on this a year,
really 10 months writing papers.
Then there was the getting ready to go
public.
So,
um,
that's kind of who I am and how I got
into this.
I just,
uh,
lapsed mathematician who gives a lot of
concern to how we produce knowledge and
what academic standards are and should
be.
So what,
why did you leave academia?
I wish I could say that it was like this
Prussian thing.
I saw the writing on the wall that it
was going mad and I wanted out,
but really it was just a number of
personal responsibilities and
commitments that led me to not want to
pursue,
um,
employment where I didn't know where I
would be placed from one post doc to the
next.
It was family commitments primarily.
But you were still interested enough to
continue with this project?
Interested enough in the academic world?
Yeah.
I never really
need to stop researching or reading and
thinking and coming up with new ideas.
Uh,
it's very difficult to do mathematics
without some institutional backing.
Uh,
math is hard as some people have
noticed.
So I didn't have the resources necessary
really to pursue mathematical research
independently,
but I found that I could dig into
philosophy and I could dig into a
psychology kind of on my own,
not professionally of course,
but,
um,
that's enough to get an idea of what I
was,
was looking at in a philosophical sense
to answer questions that I was really
deeply interested in.
Mostly the question that drove me
probably from about 2011 forward was,
you know,
what do people really mean?
What are they talking about when they
say the word God?
And so I really got involved in talking
about they're thinking about religion.
That's what led me to religious and
moral psychology,
trying to understand why people,
uh,
believe things that they do and why
they,
why they manifest their beliefs in
certain ways.
And ultimately because I was,
you know,
that kind of a guy,
I just wanted to find out what I figure.
I live in the southeast us,
so really religious area.
People talk to me about their belief in
God all the time.
I hear it constantly at different levels
from the,
you know,
yeah,
there's,
I,
I kind of believe level all the way to
the borderline insane level of
conviction to very implausible
propositions level.
And I wanted to understand,
I know the people talking about ideas
like God means something when they saved
the term.
It's something very,
not just do they mean something.
They need something very important to
themselves.
And I wanted to figure out from a
perspective that didn't rely upon the
religious,
the theology or the religious mythology
or narrative,
what they were speaking to as articles
within,
in the material world.
And so I became very interested in that
and spent a number of years reading and
writing about it.
And by the way,
the kind of culture war,
if you want to call it that progressed.
It's seeing what was happening to people
I was interested in.
I'm Sam Harris for example,
was,
was certainly one of these people.
You see these people get called racist
or sexist for what seemed to be nothing.
And you try to dig into it again with
the interest in meaning of words,
kept seeing these references back to
these,
you know,
power dynamics and um,
sociological definitions that that only
see racism or sexism is structural
entities that allow basically people of
people to be considered racist or sexist
just because of their identity by just
by virtue of being,
say,
a white male,
you could be racist and sexist
inevitably are.
That's exactly,
exactly.
So that's what led me to get curious
about the grievance studies.
Can.
And ultimately,
Peter,
let's hear,
let's hear from you and tell everybody
who you are and what you're up to.
I'm currently teaching philosophy at
Portland State University in the
philosophy department and I am up to
James Lindsey and I just finished a book
how to have impossible conversations
that will come out probably in 2019
decapo press
and I don't know what I'm up to now
because I made be looking at a career
change very soon.
So,
um,
we go get into that later.
But the university filed charges against
me.
They found me guilty of not seeking irb
approval and that
investigation is ongoing for the
falsifications.
We better have quite a conversation as
well about IRB approval.
That's another rabbit hole we can punch
down because that's another catastrophic
catastrophe that the University of has
inflicted upon itself over the last two
decades.
So that's something that's becoming
increasingly politicized.
So it's very difficult to understand how
you could get irb approval for a satire
or why you might need it.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Hello,
let's hear from you.
But I have a background in literature
and early,
late medieval,
early modern studies.
I'm interested in how women use the
Christian narrative to,
um,
to get all 30 and autonomy for
themselves,
sort of 1300 to 1700 things.
So I'm looking at how this change before
and after the reformation,
how the narratives changed.
But I,
um,
I left at the end of my masters.
I was intending to go back and do my phd
in medieval manuscripts.
Um,
but it's just got,
I keep going earlier and earlier because
it is so difficult to get away from the
ideology.
I'm,
I'm interested in medieval manuscripts,
but not overwhelmingly.
I want to look at social history,
but it's so difficult to do that because
there is a pressure now to do so
anachronistically to read it through
gender ideology of today.
So I have to accept that the reason I
was going to do medieval manuscripts is
because I can translate and transcribe
and this is something objective that I
can do.
I can produce an edition of texts which
aren't readily available and explain
them.
And that's the only real way that I'm
able to look at religious writing by and
about women,
men and the objective way.
And it isn't really I want to do.
So I stepped away for a year and in that
year I started writing about about
postmodernism,
about feminism,
about liberalism and ideology.
And then it just got to be so much to do
with that.
But I,
I haven't gone back at all so involved
in,
in writing about what's going on right
now.
And so that is,
I see,
well it's interesting because you,
you talked about
your,
your belief that women in the
mid stages of development of the
Christian Church we're using,
the idea is to actually liberate
themselves.
And too,
the examples from margery Kempe to
Emilia Lania and we're looking at very
different ways in which you know it
within the Catholic narrative,
for example,
women would say,
well God speaks directly to me.
He is the patriarch.
It gives me a certain or sovereignty to
disagree with a patriarchal if I'm with
my husband.
And then later after the reformation,
there was a slightly different emphasis
in which women,
you know,
everyone can interpret the Bible and
that includes women.
So there was a different kind of
authority there too.
So that,
that's generally been what I've been
interested in,
slightly different ways that women have
approached biblical texts,
biblical narratives and um,
and,
and yes,
and use them to,
to challenge sort of mainstream
interpretations.
And um,
I make some,
make some pretty good arguments.
Well,
I mean the Alanya certainly did not
recant,
mostly sweetened.
Okay.
So why don't we start by why are you
guys telling us what the genesis of this
project was?
Let's outline the project itself that
the sequence of papers that you wrote
and let's talk about the genesis of that
as well.
So take that one.
It's really kind of kind of interesting.
I don't know if your audience would know
this,
Jordan or not,
but all three of us,
you know,
we're writing a bit within what might've
been considered the new atheist vein and
working within that.
And then I was working on a book trying
to answer my big kind of early 2010 his
research question,
what do people mean when they say,
God?
I was writing a book called that I
eventually titled Everybody is wrong
about God.
And I,
Peter called me one day while I was
working on either the book itself or the
research for it.
I don't recall the specifics at the
time,
but he called me one day and said,
you know,
dude,
I think I'm going crazy.
I keep trying to tell people something
that's as obvious as can be to me.
And somebody has to believe I'm not
crazy.
Everybody thinks I'm nuts.
Please tell me I'm not crazy.
And so I said,
you know,
what is it?
And he said,
um,
I look at the way people in gender
studies use their scholarly can and the
way they produce that,
the way that they refer to it,
the fact that it seems disconnected,
uh,
in a literal sense from what's going on
in reality.
And it feels like it's their Bible.
It feels like it's a holy scripture for
something like a religion.
Am I going nuts?
And as it turned out,
the reason I started writing the book,
everybody's wrong about God,
was partly to answer my big research
question,
but it was also because I noticed that
the community built up around new
atheist activism,
which called a Selfie.
Atheism community showed almost all of
the symptoms of qualifying as a religion
at least from like Durkheim's
perspective and maybe even from some
others.
So I immediately latched onto what Pete
said and I said,
no,
you're not crazy.
I think you're probably right.
I think you are absolutely right that
the scholarly Canon in gender studies
and so on is operating like of book of
faith for something.
But I don't know exactly what this is.
And so we got curious about that
scholarly cannon kind of from that
point.
It wasn't long after that that the
infamous feminist glaciology paper came
out,
uh,
where the,
few four or five researchers published a
very well funded study showing or
claiming to show that that glaciology is
inherently sexist all the way back to
its roots.
Um,
back to,
you know,
the intrepid explorers of mountains and
polar regions.
And all this.
So it is justified by being a big,
tough guy in the 19th century or
whatever.
And that apparently somehow this
masculinist bias hangs over.
And so the answer to this is to put
feminist art projects as part of place
for science.
And it just apologies as part of glacier
science or else it's racist and sexist.
And I,
I mean I remember reading the paper
lightly at the time and thinking there's
no way this is real.
And Peter and I had a phone call,
we started looking at new peer review on
the twitter at the same time.
Oh,
you should never look at that.
Oh my God.
So
we've,
we've actually got two issues here.
Then let's say no all of a sudden
because yeah,
there's a,
there's the,
there's the issue of what's going on in
the
social justice oriented academic
disciplines and then there's a deeper
issue of how people view the world
individually and collectively.
Yes.
Through the lens of a belief system and
the probability that that belief system
will take on something approximating the
trappings of a religious movement.
Yes.
So that's a deeper question.
I mean,
one of the things that I discussed
continually with Sam Harris when we have
our series of debates was the question
of the inescapable realty of something
approximating a religious framework to
orient people in relationship to action
in the world.
Cause I like,
I happen to believe that a framework
like that is inescapable.
The question is not whether you're going
to have one,
it's which one you're going to have and
what is it going to be rooted in.
And I mean,
one of the things I think that both meet
you and Dostoyevsky warn people about in
the late 19th century was that,
um,
what,
this isn't a quote from either of them,
but it's something approximating someone
else whose name I don't remember.
Um,
he who believes in nothing will end up
believing in anything.
And there's something,
there's something in that that's
extraordinarily deep as far as I'm
concerned.
All right,
so you were interested in religious
phenomenology and then you guys started
to see that,
um,
as
far as you were concerned,
a variety of different causes.
I academic or academic movements were
taking on the trappings of a religious,
they were starting to look religious in
their approach and in their application
of their beliefs right on the,
on the social justice end of it.
Right.
Community for example,
was definitely engaging in of course
they had kind of their uh,
their unique vocabulary that they speak
to one another end and identify one
another by,
uh,
which is kind of like an ecclesiastical
vocabulary,
but if social justice and then they were
definitely involved,
what,
what they call political correctness is
in practice,
virtually identical to what you see with
people crying.
Blasphemy.
Um,
so these parallels started to stick out
at the same time,
the way that we started looking at the
real peer review twitter account and the
way that they seem to be producing their
knowledge that they could then refer to
virtually replicates special revelation,
the,
they came up with their ideas,
they believe that they came from some
morally backed source of,
uh,
of goodness and then put them forth.
And then were they were,
were morally vetted and given an
epistemological status they didn't
deserve.
As a result can,
why do you think the sources,
the sources at the time I had no idea,
but now after having done the project,
I think the source is actually what I've
come to call a postmodern mythology.
That our social reality is conditioned
upon use of language and representation
and it's all done in service to power
dynamics that underlie how society
works.
Those power dynamics are trapped up in
identity and um,
mediated primarily through language in,
in media
identified the sources of that.
And not only me obviously,
but I've identified the sources of that
beliefs with the French postmodernist
movement.
Fundamentally,
other people trust some of it back
farther to what's essentially something
approximating a Marxist doctrine,
which is the doctrine of which is the
doctrine of power relations,
I would say.
Sure.
We'll have any criticisms or further
comments on that.
Let's call it genealogy genealogy or
Lynn or Helen.
Helen.
Good.
Yeah,
no,
I,
I largely agree with the idea that we
had,
uh,
quite a profound epistemic shift in the
late sixties with the rise of the
postmodernists.
I disagree with people who crying kind
of relate this closely to Marxism.
I,
I think it's clear that they,
they have a common ancestor and that
they have certain ideas in common.
But if we conflate Marxism and
postmodernism too close to the,
on more than those yeah.
That,
that sort of oppressor and oppressed
group,
that surge of them.
Um,
false consciousness,
these sort of key ideas which really
worth floating around at the same time
and they've come up in the same place.
If we conflate those two closely and we
are not looking at the really profound
differences in epidemiology in which
Marxism was really trying to continue
and modernist project,
it was totalitarian,
it was objective,
this most of the,
and it went sort of in a straight line
and the,
if there was a word for the extremes of
Marxism,
it,
this totalitarianism,
if there's a word for the extremes of
postmodernism,
its disintegration.
It's fragmentation.
So we're looking now at something very
different,
something very intangible that is coming
in and,
and it's saying we cannot access and
objective truth.
Everything is created in discourses,
empowers us in systems of power and
privilege.
So why in the world is power privilege
then like,
I mean it still seems that the
postmodernists are willing to assume
that the pursuit of power is,
first of all,
it's obvious that everyone's pursuing
it,
but it's also okay for those who don't
have it to pursue it.
So it's not as if they've abandoned the
idea as far as I can tell of a,
of a linear narrative towards some end,
the end seems to me to be power.
And so why is that justifiable from the
postmodern perspective,
given that linear movement and Mehta
narratives aren't justifiable
because of the change that happened in
the late eighties so when socal for
example,
he,
he did his hopes.
What he was looking at was this collect
sort of pure postmodernism.
This I'm very sort of intangible idea
that an objective reality context is
that we can't grasp anything,
that everything is a construct.
But what happened in the 80s gradually
was that this just after prolific
amounts of writing,
it just kind of fizzled because once you
disintegrated and dismantled absolutely
everything and it's all in a mess on the
floor,
you have got no where to go with this.
So we started seeing then the rising
materialist feminism,
first of all,
um,
and then within sort of critical race
approaches,
intersectionality in queer theory in
post-colonialism particularly,
we started seeing a change towards,
okay,
so everything is a cultural construct,
but we can't address anything if we
don't accept that a certain group of
people in a certain place at a certain
time experience certain things.
So what we're looking at now is an
objective reality that oppression and
systems of power exist.
But
hmm,
everything else is socially constructed.
So the fundamental power,
but that construct has power.
Yes,
it is objective.
It true that power is benefiting
straight white men and disadvantages
women of color,
trans women,
et Cetera.
So this,
this was the change that happened then.
So now it's politically actionable.
And this,
I mean,
it couldn't Kimberle crenshaw put this
most explicitly when she said it's
politics applied to postmodern theory.
Okay,
so we want to get this straight because
it's very,
very important.
So you just,
you distinguish the postmodern movement
from the Marxist movement because the
Marxism Marxists,
we're still moving in a single
direction.
And you considered that still a part of
the modernist project,
you acquainted Marxism and postmodernism
in so far as they both adult,
let's say an oppressor,
oppression,
narrative.
Yes.
Although many other things do to,
and often that that's quite warranted.
I mean the,
the American revolution for example,
was an oppressor,
oppressed revelations.
There was no doubt,
there's no doubt that power and power
differentials exists.
The issue is not,
there are other realities that might be
considered
truly yes wallet and whether it's
reasonable to reduce everything to a
single dimension of motivation.
So the postmodern project collapses into
its own nihilism and something emerges
out of the ashes.
And that's the assumption that a
transcendent reality does in fact exist,
but they only defining feature of that
transcendent reality is the existence of
power in the existence of power
differential.
And that's associated with identity.
But then then the question becomes,
there's,
there's a question that goes underneath
that even,
which is,
well,
why is it,
why is it that that is accepted as the
fundamental reality?
Because there's no rationale for that.
And postmodernism itself,
in fact,
auditors should criticize them.
Did they,
do they do it very much?
And then this is the argument that goes
on repeatedly with the old style
postmodernist saying this isn't
postmodernism.
And so are we.
We've tended to call it applied
postmodernism,
John Nurse to build it,
the poem wage cluster because it's just
a set of ideas about identity,
about power,
about privilege,
about language,
the importance of language and um,
and,
and hierarchies and things which have
come from postmodernism,
which have got politicized.
And then within activism have got
condensed into kind of user friendly
chunks and further bastardized.
So we can't,
we can't take this away from
postmodernism.
It didn't come from anywhere else.
But neither is it the,
the,
the pure sort of deconstructive or
poststructuralist or any of that at that
whole sort of massive range of theory
that that existed from the late sixties
into the mid eighties that that died.
It sits,
gone.
It's fragmented itself as it was always
bound to do.
So to drive to your question about why
or how they justified this change,
um,
I'll just say we called this,
this set of disciplines
or approaches,
grievance studies for a reason.
It's about grievances.
It's the politics of grievance.
So they feel aggrieved,
therefore they feel justified in trying
to disrupt power.
They see that exists and declined power
for themselves.
It's social revenge.
That's what they're,
that's what they're animus is.
That's their moral justification for,
for continuing to fragment and to chase.
The very thing they say is,
you know,
the great corruptor of man,
which has power.
Okay,
so it doesn't,
so it doesn't really matter if this is
true,
and I do,
I have some sympathy with that claim.
It doesn't matter that there are
philosophical incoherencies within the
structure,
within the intellectual structure at
all.
What matters is that there's an animus
and a motive,
and the motive is fundamentally
something approximating revenge.
Why?
Why would you say,
look,
why would you say revenge and not
justice?
Like,
and,
and this,
this goes to another issue,
which is all the Asley,
all three of you oppose this movement.
And we've already decided in this
discussion that it's something like the
revenge of the mar marginalized,
but the marginalized could well object.
Well,
this isn't revenge.
You only see it that way because you're
part of the privileged power group and
it's actually a search or a search for,
it's a search.
It's genuine search for justice,
social justice orientated that that's
what we have to remember.
This is speaking on behalf of women and
racial and sexual minorities.
Most members of every group did,
do not ascribe to it.
They're,
they're politically diverse.
So it's,
um,
that's a good point.
That's a good point.
So that's one of the reasons that,
that the claim for the pursuit of
justice is invalidated.
It's that there's no evidence whatsoever
that the activist types who dominate
these disciplines are valid
representatives of the communities that
they purport to Stanford.
In fact,
if you surveyed the communities
themselves in any reasonable manner,
then the communities indicate their lack
of agreement with,
with this way of looking at the world.
Yeah.
Yes,
of course.
There is also the,
the,
the complicating element that nearly
always appears that you do have kernels
of truth on both sides of that
discussion.
There are legitimate questions of
justice that are being tied up into
this.
And then there are legitimate reasons to
see it as being motivated primarily by
something approximating revenge or
grievance or reparations or something
like that.
And they get intertwined.
And as you were mentioning with anytime
you're working with postmodern
epistemologies,
there's no reason to expect consistency.
They reject consistency as,
as,
as a bug in the system.
Uh,
they're unrepentant that unrepentant
about being inconsistent.
That's no small point.
And,
and I think people watching that,
that point needs to be punched hole.
So Jim,
could you speak to a little about that?
Well,
yeah,
it's um,
the,
the idea that you would be consistent is
one of the ideas that would be caught up
in the western philosophical tradition,
as they would phrase it.
It's caught up in the exact tradition
that was bred of white and male power.
And so that needs to be disrupted
because that power inherently from the
perspective of this Worldview,
that power inherently corrupt,
but more importantly in inherently
always asked to preserve and maintain
and legitimize itself.
So the demand for consistency becomes
itself an act of oppression against
people.
Exactly.
That all seems reasonable to me.
So,
so look,
so,
so here's a peculiar thing and it's an
observation of something approximating,
let's say it's Friday,
a notion of projection.
The people who are pushing this
viewpoint,
art,
legitimate representatives of their
communities in any real sense of the
matter.
And they push a particular viewpoint
that has very little academic
credibility as far as I'm concerned.
And,
and is primarily concerned with
political activism and with the
obtaining or the justification of
obtaining power.
Now we could assume that this is being
done on behalf of the people who are
putting forward the doctrine.
And so to me,
see,
I've come to understand that part of the
reason that people claim to their belief
systems is because they have,
the reason they have the moral authority
to occupy the hierarchical position that
society has granted them is because
they're regarded as experts in a,
in a belief structure.
And if the year that their claim to that
expertise is questioned in their moral
justification for occupying their
position is eradicate it and it's their
position gives them purpose in life and
that protects them from uncertainty and
anxiety.
It's not the belief structure itself.
You see it's for factor there experts in
the belief system and that justifies
their position in the hierarchy.
So they put forward this claim to
continue justifying the fact that they
occupied very perversely.
And this is the fruit of the projection
is so very perversely,
the very positions of power whose
existence a credit sucks.
This would be a university professor
types in particular that seems
reasonable to you or,
or is there something wrong with that?
Oh,
the courts actually with what I've drawn
from reading John Height for example,
who talks about psychosocial,
a psycho social evaluation and the way
that human beings do that with one
another.
How we identify where we stand in our
social and moral hierarchies,
uh,
and how we,
where we position ourselves and others
each other in relation to one another.
And that one of those three dimensions
he named divinity.
And so that would be the part you're
speaking to.
So we gain,
we gained status in the hierarchy
through our closeness of kin.
So if you and I are friends,
you rank me higher than I probably
deserve because that's how humans do.
And we gain status by reputation and
that's why we care what Michael Jordan
thinks about politics.
And we gain status by,
um,
our moral standing,
which is what John Height called
divinity.
And of course he explored it primarily
in the happiness hypothesis with regard
to his trips,
I think the India and seeing a
traditional religion and then comparing
that directly against the so called
weird societies in Western democracies.
And,
uh,
I think that what we're actually seeing
in a lot of these cases as we're seeing
partly at least people are acting out.
Um,
what,
what often gets conflated with religion
in fact is that they're acting out the
need to fulfill or participate in that
third dimension of psychosocial
evaluation.
Although in secular societies we throw
out the,
the explicit religious structure for it
and we have to find it in other ways.
So that's what you're actually talking
about.
They,
they occupy a Mo,
a moral expertise,
not more likes for TC gives them
standing within the prevailing moral and
Social Maloo.
And then that defines their place in the
community as in both in terms of
prestige and in terms of hierarchy
standard.
They're basically acting out precisely
what they're accusing all other
disciplines of doing
control,
irony and the differences to see.
The thing is,
the difference as far as I'm concerned,
is that if you look at a discipline like
engineering,
which I think is perhaps as close to the
polar opposite of this,
this might be managed.
One of the things that engineers do is
look at the world in a certain way.
But another thing they do is build
bridges.
Exactly right.
That's right.
There's an objective real world,
uh,
direction to their,
to their philosophizing and their
beliefs that results in something of
tangible and university recognize
benefit to the community at March and
something that can fail.
Yes.
Right,
right,
right.
Also,
that's very important.
Okay.
Now,
okay,
next issue.
So now the first issue,
first of the next two issues saying is
why is it that you three found herself
in a position where you decided to take
this on as a critical project and why is
it that so few other academics are doing
so
I don't have good answers for why so few
academics are doing so.
Cause I don't want to just blatantly
call people cowards that I don't know.
But you don't get treated well for
fighting.
Let's dig into that a bit.
Okay.
Because I think,
I think cowardice is one or fear.
And let's,
let's start here.
Let's call it fear.
And let's also note that the fear is
well justified,
very justice.
Yeah,
that's correct.
Right.
Well Peter,
you're in a great position to speak to
that because look what's happening to
you.
Yeah,
so I don't know if you want to go down
the path and what's happened to me yet,
but I,
I think you're right.
Our mutual friend,
Bret Weinstein said to me that academia
where we had a conversation about
academia self selecting for cowardice,
and I think it's a process that people
go through it before they have tenure,
where they're afraid to buck the system,
afraid to challenge ideas.
They're afraid to question because who
they won't get tenure and then once they
do get tenure,
then they won't make you a bit more
climate.
Yeah.
That's the same thing happens in
corporations at the middle manager
level.
Like it's not a disease that is endemic
to academia.
No,
no,
it's not.
But it's one variable in a suite of
variables that we have to take a look
at.
The other one is the culture in which
the cultural milieu that Jim spoke about
in which people are terrified to be
called sexist,
racist,
bigot.
So they don't challenge those.
I'm even hesitant to say the things that
don't challenge,
but I'll say it like race and Iq or
trans issues,
trans bathroom issues.
If you teach an ethics class,
people won't really dig into those
issues in a substantive way.
But I think that there are many factors,
but not just one,
but it's just showing that people will
come up to Jim and myself and I haven't
spoken explicitly to Helen about this
and they'll thank me.
Yup.
Oh,
thank you so much.
great.
Can you do that publicly?
No,
no,
no.
The same thing happened to me.
I think we should talk about what's
happening to you because we talk about
fear.
We can talk about cowardice,
we can talk about justifiable cause
there's no,
there's no pleasure in being isolated
and moms and undermine and fired.
Right.
So the apprehension of that is not
merely coward,
it's,
it's realistic.
And I'm not underestimating the
potential role,
the additional role of cowardice.
But then there's another issue too here
and I'd be thinking about,
it's like,
to me,
many of these postmodern activist
propositions are so fundamentally absurd
and so academically weak that most
serious social scientists and pretty
much all serious stem types,
the stem researchers have just ignored
them.
They thought they were beneath contempt
and right
seriously mean that because I look at an
idea,
you know,
a brilliant postmodern activist idea
like intersectionality where like
patriarchy theory or like white
privilege,
all you have to do is spend an hour
thinking through those things critically
and you realize that there's out
solutely nothing whatsoever to the
methodologically or conceptually
as jen was saying,
you know that that can be a kernel of
Chris in things.
But when they are theoretically built,
I mean obviously there,
there,
there are societies in which white
people are regarded more positively on
average,
but this is something that can be
measured in three which can be looked
at,
which can be talked about.
And we don't actually have that way.
We have imaginary knapsacks and talk of
complicity and I'm an epistemological
environments in which white people
literally can't understand what's going
on.
So we it,
we get a big mess
and it's,
it's,
there's a kernel of truth in that and so
that gives them the opportunity to kind
of retreat to this sensible space where
they'll say,
but there is racism and that there is
sexism.
Well,
yes of course there is.
But what you're doing here with these
theoretical concepts is,
is not looking realistically and
reasonably at that
adoption.
Right?
It's like,
okay well racism is a problem in sexism
is a problem we'll say.
And any form of discrimination that
isn't associated with the hypothetical
outcome of the project is a problem.
But there are methods that everyone
who's a decent social scientist knows to
measure those and to estimate the
proportion of the variance in the
outcome problem that those issues are
accounting for.
And the postmodern and activist types to
absolutely none of that.
Yeah.
I mean why would they?
Because they don't care about their
agenda driven in their truth oriented.
So there's going to be no point to even
think like that.
Well they also can't,
they don't have the methods training.
Exactly.
So,
so that also provides additional impetus
for being motivated to criticize those
that do because it's a lot easier than
say,
seeing the reality and the consequences
of your own ignorance.
Let's talk about what's happening to you
because I want to know about the cost
that you're buried for this and then
we'll go back to why you guys decided to
do what you did.
So psu,
like many college campuses has become an
ideological community and I've
demonstrated that I don't fit that mold
and I suspect that they're going to go
to great lengths to get rid of me.
So what's happened is I've been found
guilty of Nazi he and Irb approval.
And
can you tell the viewers what that means
and and provide some background detail.
Okay.
So our be approval is there's a,
it's to call the IRB Institutional
Review Board.
And whenever you do a,
an experiment on human subjects,
human beings or animals,
by the way,
you need to go through the irb and you
need to get permission and you detail
exactly what it is that you're going to
do.
And they say to you,
well,
you have to change this.
You have to do this,
don't do this,
etc. And then they give you permission.
Okay.
These systems,
just a little more background,
these systems were originally set up
fundamentally to monitor relatively or
potentially dangerous medical
experimentation,
but they've expanded their per view so
that now it's impossible for anybody
who's an academic in any institution to
even interview people without seeking
permission from a very vast and rigid
bureaucratic structure that's easily
politicized.
Yeah.
They came out of,
and they do exist for good reasons.
The Nuremberg trials may lay,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And people were in that envelope has,
has,
uh,
the number of experiments or the number
of things are calling,
are under that umbrella continues to
increase.
We can talk about the ethics of the RV
more generally,
but in our case are particularly mind
that the IRB has no,
Jim and James and Helen don't fall under
the off season pses rv so they can't be
sanctioned.
I however,
allegedly can can be sanctioned,
so I'd been found guilty on that first
charge,
which,
well now look,
let's,
let's tell everybody what is published.
A sequence of papers,
how many papers in journals is it?
We wrote 27 of them were accepted and
four were published
on the cusp of publication,
for example.
Okay,
let's get it straight here.
These are satirical publications that
were published in hypothetically serious
academic journals and now Peter,
you're being gone after for not seeking
institutional review board permission to
publish studies that didn't exist.
Yeah,
two,
two things.
That's the first thing I'd been found
guilty of that and it's escalated to the
provost and the president of the
university and I believe that the
provost is a former gender studies
scholar and I'll just,
I'll let that sit there.
I do,
I do.
I can't pronounce the president's name
to be blunt with you.
And the provost is new provost.
I'm not avoiding the question.
I just don't,
that's fine.
We can always put that in the
description of the video.
So,
so what are you guilty of exactly?
Because these studies didn't exist.
You didn't undertake research on any
human subjects.
They've decided that the journal editors
and peer reviewers are the human
subjects that we were studying.
So not the studies themselves,
but go up one level of Metta to the fact
that we were studying the culture of um,
Journal,
Journal Review and publication.
So the editors who are not anonymous and
then the anonymous peer reviewers are
considered to be the human subjects of
our,
that's supposed to be,
I suppose.
I see.
So that's supposed to be distinguishable
from you thinking and writing about the
things that you encounter in your own
life,
for example,
which is also what now it's supposed to
be subject to irb approval.
So,
so okay.
So there's a lot of moving parts to
this.
So we need to break it down.
I wonder,
I want to continue with the,
excuse me,
guilty of not seeking irb approval.
That can include turn up to termination
from my current position.
And uh,
I just want to speak to that before I
talk about the data fabrication charges.
So I don't agree with the decision,
but I definitely understand the
pressures that they have on them to do
something.
Who knows what's happening.
Pressures from a hope.
These activist types are a very tiny
proportion of the population.
So,
and when we're talking about pressure,
what exactly do we mean?
Well,
there was an anonymous hid piece by 12
or 11 of my colleagues published in the
student newspaper,
the Portland Vanguard,
and they may be a small representation.
I,
it's unclear to me in academia,
I don't think there are a small
proportion of the pie.
They are a large and I think that they
wield institutionalized power and have
weaponized things like title line
against people they don't like.
Um,
so there's that.
But I do want to say,
I don't really know what's happening
behind the scenes.
I,
my guess is these,
this group is extraordinarily vocal,
but what they're faced with now is a
decision for what kind of university
they want to be.
Is it one that uses power to support
freedom of inquiry and pursuit of the
truth or do they want to protect social
justice at all costs?
And the fabrication of data thing is
interesting because that's an ongoing,
it's currently ongoing investigation.
And again,
those are very,
very serious charges.
Let's look at it here too.
There was a very big difference.
Let's get this very clear between a self
admitted satire,
which had historical precedent and which
has ethical justification,
even if you don't agree with the
justification data fabrication data
fabrication occurs when you put Devin
and you claim that it's truthful
representation of a real world
situation.
Yeah.
Obviously that's distinct from satire
and comedy.
Everyone understands that distinction.
Well,
the guy,
the idea is that those rules were put in
there for very good reasons and that is
people wouldn't use that to advance
their careers,
which,
uh,
and they wanted to hide the results so
they don't,
didn't want anybody to see what it was.
So the problem with that is that it
would,
as socal wrote,
that it would contaminate the,
uh,
research lines in perpetuity.
So what the success of our project
dependent upon it being revealed so that
no longer applies and the idea that we
would somehow,
not only am I not benefited from this,
but this is coming a tremendous cost to
me.
So
it's,
in my opinion,
it is,
uh,
a grow task abuse of what it means to
fabricate data.
And,
uh,
I mean it means be interesting to see.
It'll be interesting to see what happens
and be in as you see when it goes to
court.
Okay.
And so,
so yeah,
tell me about the proceedings when it
goes to court.
What kind of card is it going to?
I don't know.
I mean,
first let me even take a step back from
there.
So if you look at the timeline of events
when this occurred,
and I don't have that off the top of my
head,
but,
uh,
the,
when I was falling guilty from the Irb,
it's been a series of,
uh,
of Nazi need,
irb approval.
There was a series of a time when the
university president could just end this
just like that.
You can say,
well,
we're going to put a,
a letter of reprimand in Europe.
Uh,
we're going to
make it and it will
guilty of who found you guilty.
That was the IRB was December 14th.
I see.
So the IRB is policing its own it's own
policies here.
Yeah.
So that was for the irb charge,
the open data falsification charges open
and still being investigated.
Uh,
and that actually started I think like
two or three days after we went public.
He got an email and said,
you've been summoned to a meeting.
And we were all in Portland together at
the time in October.
The IRB,
which purports to be an ethics
committee,
doesn't have any problem with the ethics
of policing themselves.
You might want to point that out very
strongly because they're not in a
position to be policing accordance with
their own policies.
Conflict of interest.
Clearly there's something appalling
about that.
And it's not surprising because there's
plenty of hauling about the
institutional review boards.
Guilty,
guilty.
It's been escalated to the president.
And again,
the president could just decide just
like that,
you know,
we're just going to put a letter in his
file of reprimand and we're going to
move on.
And I think that the whole problem would
be,
uh,
ended,
except my guess is that there are a lot
of people crying for vengeance right now
against me.
Right?
So they want to hang you out to dry as
an object lesson to people who would
dare to do the things that you three
have done.
Because I'm a heretic and I'm a blast
femur and I have attack their cannons
and there has to be some price that's
paid for this.
That's my guests when they're thinking.
And then the fabrication of data charge,
again,
that's a very serious charge of okay
data and those rules are put in,
put in place for a reason.
I don't think a court would find,
I mean it would be interesting to see
when this goes to quarter or if it does
even go to court.
The idea that this was fabricated either
for personal gain or that would have to
not be revealed at some time and that
the future lines of literature would be
contaminated and polluted.
It's just,
it's just not true and I think that,
well also a clear,
it's a career ended in charge,
so that's partly why it's being brought
against you,
right?
Data fabrication,
there isn't anything,
well,
there isn't any same thing worse within
the domain of science,
then you can do that.
You can do that.
That
that's really unfortunate and
preposterous because the data
fabrication occurred intentionally in
the sense that we wanted to find out if
they could detect,
because we suspected from the very
beginning as we were kind of discussing
earlier,
that these people who largely work in
the humanities are not equipped to do
social science,
but that's ultimately what they're
basically doing.
And so we wanted to see if they could
detect utterly ridiculous data or data
that were clearly cherry picked or data
or conclusions I should say,
that were drawn from data that aren't
warranted.
And so we wrote papers that included,
in this case,
for example,
a dog park paper,
just transparently ridiculous data.
And in fact,
the first draft of that paper,
even we knew the data were so bad that
they were probably going to ask to see
it.
We thought that's the end of the road,
the papers then.
So we'll talk about the dog park paper.
Why don't you go through the papers that
have been published just briefly
and tell us why they're transparently
ridiculous because that's also tension,
right?
Yeah.
The dog park paper,
um,
was the first one we had accepted in
February.
And it chronicles a,
it's a feminist scholar putatively
that's chronicling dog rape culture by
examining dog humping in Portland dog
parks.
And,
uh,
then draws conclusions from that using
black feminist criminology as a tool to
conclude that it would be appropriate to
train men as we train dogs if only it
were politically feasible.
So we have to come up with a
metaphorical equivalent.
And that concludes that oppression of
dogs based on perceived gender is real.
And the reason that that was allegedly
concluded was we claimed that,
um,
humans intervened in,
broke up a gay dog rate much more
frequently in vigorously,
then they broke up straight dog rate.
And the paper,
I mean it's already a bit weird about
these things.
The paper,
the paper included,
for instance,
the detail that the scholar sat in the
dog park for a thousand hours over the
course of a year,
but never in the heavy rain and
observed,
uh,
and then examined personally closely
examined the genitals of just short of
10,000 dogs,
which if you've been to a dog park,
you've probably realized the same people
bring their dogs almost every day.
It's,
there's not 10,000 dogs in any dog park
in a year,
but never mind to develop a reputation
for looking at dogs genitals.
Yeah,
I think so.
And then immediately turning to ask
their owners,
excuse me sir,
could you tell me your sexual
orientation?
Because that's what the paper says.
Wait,
10,000 dogs,
Jen Genitals,
a 10,000 dogs and then interrogated
their owners as to their sexual
orientations.
It includes details that are irrelevant,
like weather dogs use the bathroom and
the other dogs are in the food bowl.
The water bowl,
it talks about,
you know,
the way people would break up dog
fights,
like doing jumping jacks and singing.
We thought this data was so absurd that
we put in the first draft,
which the journal saw align that said
that we took the data and put it in a
recycle bin so that they couldn't
possibly ask us to produce it because we
thought,
oh man,
if they asked for this data,
which is so stupid,
it's over.
So we said that we recycled the data,
which has already its own research,
ms practice and no problem.
Write it up.
Okay.
I can't believe we're having this
conversation
and listen,
the more we talk about this,
the more ridiculous it gets.
Okay,
so let's go on to another paper that's
just on unbearable.
But there was the paper where we argued
that if straight white straight man,
I'm sorry,
it doesn't matter what their racist,
if straight men were to ainslie
penetrate themselves with sex toys,
they'd become less transphobic and more
feminist.
Um,
which apparently got picked up the
slack.
They may not want to have that
conversation,
but this data was this,
this conclusion,
which was called a truly marvelous paper
and an important contribution to
knowledge by one of its reviewers.
Uh,
this paper was published,
this paper was based on interviews with
13 men,
only eight of whom were straight.
And of course it was all interview data
and it was just people saying the most
ridiculous things about their experience
of sticking things in their own butts
and then their feelings about feminism
and a concern for rape culture and their
attitudes about trans people and so on,
including one so-called social
conservative who was quoted saying he
didn't want to take part in some stupid
liberal study about sticking things up
as,
but I mean,
it's almost impossible to have looked at
this and not thought,
you know,
something's going on here.
But instead they thought,
truly marvelous paper knowledge.
It's that,
that's a second paper.
A third paper,
um,
was an ethnography allegedly of a 70
some odd year old man who went to
hooters with his Brazilian Jujitsu class
after workouts and sat there and
basically just womanized for hours upon
hours recorded something like 10,000
hours or sorry,
10,000 minutes of conversation at the
table,
which could all be summarized.
And this was an example of clear cherry
picking of data.
The only features of the conversation
that were relevant were the way that the
guys hit on the surfers are talked about
the servers,
you know,
various body parts or most importantly
how much they enjoyed the fact that
hooters provides them a place that they
can go and tell young,
attractive women what to do in a
situation in which they are
contractually obligated to fulfill
those,
those orders.
Like literally double entendre on the
work order.
Like please,
I would like some beer that's an order.
So,
um,
that was an example of clear cherry
picking and of course deriving
ridiculous conclusions.
Uh,
did you guys know while you were doing
this that you are going to get yourself
in like a boatload of trouble?
I mean,
and now I see when you're talking about
it,
you laugh.
And so you still got a sense of humor,
which is quite a remarkable thing.
You,
you did this for a long time and like,
yeah,
it's hard to believe actually that you
did manage,
do it.
I have some,
some moments especially where,
uh,
I mean we were always aware that there
would be a backlash and then when I
started actually signing the transfer of
copyright,
the documents to have the papers
actually published,
I started to feel a little like,
you know,
we might really get in some trouble for
this,
but at this point we're kind of in deep
and uh,
might as well carry on and try to finish
the experiment we had intended to,
to try to write papers for 12 months and
then spend six to eight months kind of,
you know,
following up.
The academic publishing process is slow.
They do the review,
you get it back a couple months later,
you have to do edits.
It takes maybe another month or two
before they accept or whatever.
Then publication may be another couple
of months later.
So it all,
it's slow.
So we wanted to do a lot,
you know,
six,
eight months after 12 months of writing
and that was the intended duration that
we should be wrapping up the project now
if we didn't get busted.
But about late summer,
the dog park paper got picked up,
um,
by some journalists and the real peer
review and got made fun of it and we
realized we were probably not going to
make it to the end of our intended at
year and a half ish time span.
So we ended up writing for 10 total
months,
which is a bit of time and
still under review,
which was really ashamed because I'm
fairly sure,
but I do want to speak to that Jordan
because somebody had to do this.
Yeah.
Why?
Because the ideology,
because these professors are looking at
their classrooms as an ideology mill and
they're attempting to indoctrinate
people into things about reality that
have nothing to do with reality.
They've placed an agenda ahead of the
truth and it's corroding our
institutions in it's eroding trust in
those universities and institutions.
And you identified the problem.
Many people identified the problem,
but something had to be done about it
beyond identification and calling these
people out.
We needed to show that needs to de
legitimize these cannons because there
the way that they were coming to
knowledges,
just epistemologically to to say it's
not rigorous as chow is,
is charitable.
So they're kind of a few pieces to that.
Right.
So you mentioned a little bit earlier,
we touched upon,
um,
is now familiar with the idea that
racism and sexism don't seem to mean the
same thing they meant 10 years ago you
used to be able to say racist and sexist
and amend discrimination based on race
or sex.
And it could go in any direction.
But now it's got this power,
dynamic,
privileged plus power stuff.
Everybody's talking about privilege.
So that's everywhere.
But if that's one dimension and it's
impossible to avoid that,
the sociological or grievance studies
definitions for concepts are,
are everywhere.
But there are also two other pieces of
evidence.
One that we saw before we started that
would be a paper that was done by
Charlotte,
a stern who,
how insular gender studies is.
How they literally took
the years since Steven pinker published
the blank slate 2003 until 2015 or 16
she looked at a bunch of papers,
got us a sample of those papers and
determined whether or not they
incorporated or ignored the,
uh,
information that pinker had shared as a,
as a,
as a test and found that there was an
overwhelming amount of just putting the
blinkers on and pretending that biology
still doesn't exist and that human
nature is totally social.
Part of that's not a pretense either.
Is that
a pretense here?
I mean,
the reason it's not a pretense is
because as far as I can tell,
the people who are in these disciplines,
no,
absolutely nothing whatsoever about
biology,
biology.
The more you don't want to know,
that you need to know because it's a
daunting task.
Yeah.
I want to speak to that for a moment.
If I may.
So at my university,
a course offered on the philosophy of
race,
and it would seem to me that a minimum
qualification one would need to teach
that is that one would have to have some
kind of degree in evolutionary biology.
But that does not seem to be the case.
And I think,
again,
we're seeing consistently,
you know,
race is such an explosive,
explosive topic,
but when you start with the idea that
you have the truth and then you work
backward and Cherry pick the literature,
and in this case it's extraordinarily
easy because you just go to these,
the journals and the canons of
literature and then you start teaching
them.
So what happens then is the kind of the
self fulfillment of the postmodern
condition is that they then manufacturer
pieces of information that people take
as knowledge.
We see that happening in our
institutions now and it's,
nobody's calling them out on it.
So it's again,
I say that because it speaks to your
point of why didn't we do this?
Because the public trust in these
institutions as being eroded and we're
teaching our kids things that are just
not true.
They're just totally untethered to
reality.
Even though some of these people may be
very well meaning
and there's always a citation and we
learned,
there's always a cycle with the
citation.
You want to find something that says
anything ridiculous about sex,
toys and anal taking care of,
there's questions,
power dynamics using that already.
There's always this like that that maybe
is the,
is the important thing to sort of
realize it about what we did.
I mean,
all of that ridiculous stuff that,
that Jim was saying earlier,
we were able to say that because there
was already something out there which
led to it or set it itself.
And so if you're actually looking at
what our project is,
something that's very important is our
references because to me,
some of it really,
yeah,
it's,
there's this humorous,
it's a very humorous element in it,
but on a deeper level,
what it is,
is just gathering so much of this
nonsense together,
citing it,
putting it in there and then kind of
making it do whatever it,
whatever we wanted it to do that that
was,
was the project.
Um,
and it's your point is that you have to
embed yourself tire within a preexistent
literature or it couldn't float and
like they really,
I mean a lot of the,
some of the academics have said,
well we haven't been fooled because we
still stand by the papers.
What you wrote was reasonable because
they are indistinguishable and that
really was kind of the point we wanted
to have.
We,
we've ended up with a really good
resource for anyone who wants to know
what is out there.
They can look at our references,
they can look at the arguments that they
enabled us to make.
They can look at how the reviewers,
what they rejected us for,
what they accepted us for,
what they pushed us to do.
There's a very clear pattern,
but because it is so complicated with so
few people have taken the time it would
take to read all of our papers to read
all of the comments to follow up our rem
at references.
It's not always clear that what we're
doing is putting it right in the Canon.
That is why
this has to do with the motivation of
other academics.
Not to be bothered with this.
The stuff that I'm most familiar with is
that about 80% of humanities papers get
cited zero times and the problem is that
even to go after very bad ideas in an
academically rigorous way is actually an
extraordinarily daunting task and it
might be daunting in direct proportion
to the,
to the appalling this of the ideas.
So for example,
if you're creating a very bad
undergraduate essay,
it's way more difficult to grade a d
paper than it is to grade a b d paper
has so many errors in it.
You don't even know where to start,
right?
The words are wrong,
the sentences are wrong,
the sentences aren't organized in the
paragraphs.
The paragraphs are chaotic and
disjointed and the whole thing makes no
sense and you actually have to do,
there isn't a level of criticism that
can't be applied to a very bad paper and
so it's an absolutely exhausting
intellectually apart from the danger
that it poses personally
before we assume that it's mirror lack
of character on the part of our fellow
academics that is stopping them from
taking a stand against such things.
Although I do buy the sort of entrenched
power,
this idea that emerges as perhaps an
inevitable consequence of participating
in a structured hierarchy.
It's there are,
there are many more reasons why this is
forged,
including the inappropriate,
what would you call it,
subsidization of these viewpoints for
the last 50 years.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think that's right.
It's really,
really painstaking to pour through these
papers.
And as a,
as a person,
you know,
with a commitment to science and a
background in science,
it wasn't just even painstaking.
I actually went into some pretty dark
places,
psychological places.
I remember reading the,
so I mentioned reading the glaciology
paper earlier,
the feminists physiology,
but I didn't read it in depth when we
first found it.
But when we started to do this project,
I wanted to emulate it and write one
about feminists astronomy.
And I read the thing in tremendous depth
and with great care,
taking notes all the way through and you
know,
preparing so I could could write effect
similarly.
And I shut down.
I mean,
I just almost locked myself in a room by
myself for three days in a dark
depression that
quoting
the same thing how to be when I was
writing 12 rules for life,
I wrote a chapter called don't bother
children when they're skateboarding and
it's about the discouragement,
let's say of primarily of young men as a
direct consequence of this.
The kind of rhetoric that we're
discussing and like that made me
unbearable for my family for about three
months because the more I studied it,
the more it has a really fragmented and
chaotic effect going on.
You psychologically,
and I've also seen this manifested in my
students,
you know who undergo this kind of act of
this indoctrination.
It's,
it's such a,
it's such a corrosive and cynical view
of the world that all we're,
we're all in it in our groups and then
all the groups are fighting one another
for power and that that's the
fundamental transcendent reality.
It's just,
yeah.
Now imagine,
imagine the sort of person who looks at
that as an epistomological and moral
virtue and who teaches that to their
students,
who attempts to indoctrinate their
students into these,
not even,
they don't even arrive.
So level of being false in terms of
these morally dangerous ideas.
And then they think that they're better
people as a result.
And then they think that if somebody
calls them out on it,
they're evil.
Okay,
so let's look and look at this too.
So when high he,
Ted Lukey Nofx wrote the cognitive,
the American mind,
one point they pointed out as the
American Psychological Association and
the American Psychiatric Association
should have that all of the safe space
and doctrines and trigger warning
doctrines and,
and,
and that sort of thing.
Um,
and the speech codes for example,
that are increasingly forbidding,
even sarcasm are exactly the opposite of
the approach that you would take if you
were a trained psychologist trying to
produce people who are more resilient.
You actually make them weaker and more
anxiety provoking and more anxiety
prone,
more depressed,
and more hopeless.
And I think the evidence for that,
it's absolutely clear and I think it's
appalling that it wasn't clinical
psychologists or psychiatrists who
pointed it out and so it is that the,
these doctrines are being put forth for
the benefit of those who formulate the
doctrines and that the students are
sacrificial victims in that,
in that process.
Yeah.
There's one more piece that I think is
important that goes back to what,
excuse me,
what Jim said about not seeing that a
contradiction is problematic because the
whole idea of contradiction is white
science or western science and that's
problematic is that we found that these
folks don't really value discourse and
dialogue and so they don't really value
having ideas challenged and questioned.
That's not there.
Their reason for teaching these ideas in
the first place and if I may give you a
quick example,
excuse me.
Well in State University wants to
include or has included at this point a,
a course on native American philosophy,
which,
which I think is a great idea.
And well,
somebody in the audience asked the
question and the question was,
I went to a presentation and the
question is individual asked was,
well,
what do we do as settlers,
as colonialists when we want to question
or challenge these ideas and native
American philosophy.
And the presenter said,
you know,
I've struggled with this.
It's very difficult for me,
but the bottom line was it shouldn't,
it should be exempt from traditional
tools that we have used for other
disciplines.
You know,
the dialectic challenging.
And so that first of all,
that places me in an almost impossible
position.
What am,
what am I supposed to do?
Say,
you know,
why is it exempt?
It should play by the rules that every
other philosophy because then I become
the guy who hates western,
who hates,
um,
uh,
indigenous people who hates indigenous
philosophy.
And then I'm the tool of the patriarchy,
which gets back to what you were
questioning or asking before is why do
we have this violence in academia and
what's the problem with it?
So I think part of the problem is that
these folks don't value discourse.
They don't value dialog,
they don't value open expression,
they don't,
well,
they view that.
And again,
there's a paper for this,
they view that as a type of violence.
Words are a type of mine,
so type of verbal violence.
And so then their students develop
brutal epistemologies because they've
never heard the other side of the story.
Right.
And they develop them just when they
should be developing resilient,
resilient
be correct.
And
yeah,
and as a litmus test,
I always,
I always ask folks why,
who are gender studies in my class or
study in the,
in the grievance studies fields,
what,
why is it Martha Nussbaum is criticism
of Judith Butler taught hair,
single single students as,
yes,
I've learned about that in my class.
Well,
they don't,
they don't teach that because they have
a prevailing orthodoxy and they want to
indoctrinate with it and
they've kind of hijack the
administration.
And as I said before,
they've weaponized offices of diversity,
inclusion,
etc. To punish people who are heretics
and who questioned or challenged.
Okay.
So we're going to run out of time.
We're running down to about 10 minutes
here.
So I want to,
here's a question that I want to race to
all three of you have to,
I think one is why in the world should
anybody outside of academia care about
this?
That's the first thing and very careful
answer that.
And the second is,
um,
for each of you,
what's been the personal consequence of
this and would you have repeated it if
you knew what the consequences were
going to be?
So let's,
let's start with the first one.
Why in the world should they,
why in the world should anyone care that
some half did?
Academic Journal published an insane
paper by three renegade,
uh,
academics about what,
about dorm rate of all the absurd,
uh,
of,
of the observed observed topics.
It's so surreal that it seems
virtually in comprehensible sensible
people should avoid it.
So what's the answer to that?
Well,
go ahead Helen.
The university.
Okay.
It,
it is our source of knowledge
production.
If we look back through history,
when our cultures were Christian,
the new knowledge about this was coming
from the universities.
When we had the scientific revolution,
when we went into the enlightenment,
this was coming from the universities.
These things don't stay in the
universities.
We have seen it is coming out in what is
essentially happened with the kind of
identity studies that we're looking at
is that it has been made directly
actionable by activists,
has been tagged onto the end of the
civil rights movements and liberal
feminism and gay pride.
When those movements have started to see
diminishing returns and people wanted to
continue,
then it's,
it's tacked onto the end of that to a
society which has just seeing the end of
empire,
the end of Jim Crow and is geared
towards towards social justice and it is
it,
is it a c did here
it's also a warning to the corporations
because it's permeating the HR
departments don't.
Yes,
it's going to stay in the universities
and don't be thinking that you can
import 2% of it without importing the
other 98% will.
Yeah.
People Leave University and they join
these industries.
Also,
there's pressure on corporations to
comply with the reigning moral
orthodoxy.
I mean,
I don't think that the average business
owner or the average person in the
street knows anything about Sukkot or
crenshaw or even thinks much about this,
but it is in the air now and it is.
It is affecting,
it is affecting everything and we do
need to take it seriously without sort
of having a moral,
we need to
look at it calmly and empirically and
address it as it actually is.
And what should we do about it?
That's the next issue because the
podcast,
no.
Okay,
fine.
That's another point.
Then the final question for all three of
you is and maybe one at a time.
Um,
when you do it again,
I would,
yeah,
I would definitely do it again.
Um,
okay.
So we know that you're an unrepentant
troublemaker
in trouble.
I've also found like my one great talent
in the world and I feel like I've made
my own life obsolete now.
Okay.
Wonderful.
Bullshit artist.
If anybody's looking for one,
um,
yeah,
I would definitely do it again.
It's worth the risk.
I think it needed to be done.
Helen,
let's ask you next and then we'll get
let,
Peter has the last word because he's the
one that's got the most on the line at
the moment.
I was imagining all sorts of things from
being arrested under sort of hate speech
acts to being physically attacked
because I have an uncommon name.
I've had an awful lot online abuse.
I've got some persistent store because
that has a sentiment that I probably
won't get into a phd program in my own
country.
They,
somebody in Germany,
it's been,
um,
it's been quite nice.
Okay.
Peter
had to be done.
There's a crisis in the universities.
Does a crisis with knowledge production
is a crisis of confidence
and a heavy price to me.
And I have had to weigh out my family
obligations,
helping put my son through school,
you know,
being a part of
being in a relationship in which I
economically contribute to the house.
But this had to be done.
And if I am a consequence of this,
then so be it.
It had to be done.
Yeah.
Well,
Peter Work,
there's a bunch of us who are not
particularly inclined to let you be a
sole sacrificial victim.
So if you're a university wants to get
too stupid with you,
then um,
let's,
let's assume that they're going to be
consequences.
I sincerely appreciate your support from
the bottom of my heart.
Thank you.
Yeah,
well enough is enough.
So,
well look guys,
it was really good talking to you.
All of them.
I think that you're quite the
surreal bunch of troublemakers and
perhaps exactly what this crazy
situation requires and
well,
and I hope that,
I hope Peter,
that that things work out for you
properly over the next few years.
It's going to be a tough haul for a
while.
There's no doubt.
Are you getting any student support at
your university?
Getting a lot of students support the
university,
but you know,
I have to be,
people would threaten to attack me a few
weeks ago.
Someone spit at me,
my colleagues literally while walked on
the card or they'll turn
their heads.
It's,
it's uh,
but then you know,
the uncomfortable things,
not much different from the typical
university.
Yeah,
it's,
it has seem to be.
I am.
I mean,
I,
I want to be blunt with you.
It is a concern for my safety in
Portland when I leave the house now.
Yeah.
And I've now been Trenton on more than
one occasion by people and I'm
concerned.
Do you find the threats credible?
I mean,
I know every,
every threat is upsetting,
but like are you actually in a situation
where you have some apprehension about
leaving your house
or,
I won't have any apprehension.
Uh,
look,
I,
you know,
I wake up in the morning and I get
emails and tweets,
people telling me how stupid I am and
wouldn't,
you know,
bad person I am and how I'm a homophobe
and racist,
et Cetera.
I then,
it doesn't do anything to me.
But when I walk out in the street,
so the bar a few weeks ago,
or maybe a few months ago,
I don't even know mine for timelines,
but you know,
someone,
someone came up to me and he started
harassing me as fortunately as with my
Jujitsu coach,
John Davis,
a black belt in Jujitsu.
And he immediately pulled up the chair
beside us and I kept saying,
let's talk.
Let's have a conversation.
No,
he followed me in the bathroom.
I came out of the bathroom.
Finally,
I said,
look,
I don't know what's happening.
I don't know why you're so upset and I'm
happy to talk to you.
And he said,
I don't want to talk to Peter.
I want to hurt.
And it,
oh,
that's pretty,
that's pretty serious.
Yeah.
And then it happened again on the street
when I was surrounded about we can half
ago by people,
I assume they're anti for people or
something clearly wanted to hurt me.
Uh,
so,
you know,
I am,
I am concerned.
I am concerned about
those for people who haven't been
through it.
It's very hard for people who haven't
been through that sort of thing to
understand just exactly how distressing
that kind of occurrence is.
Not only because it happens,
but because it could happen again and it
could become more serious.
So I'm really sorry to hear that.
I didn't realize it didn't come to that.
That's,
that's no laughing matter.
I appreciate that.
It's got anything to do with you.
And there's,
there's this will stick because there's
insults,
leaflets and notices and yeah,
that kind of stuff doesn't bother me.
It's when it's in the physical world
where I feel,
I feel someone,
I mean if someone tells you they're
going to hurt you,
you should take their word for it.
Yes,
definitely.
When,
when it's that direct and when it
started in your face,
those threats are credible.
That that's,
that's a real,
that's a real danger.
So,
well look,
I'm really sorry to hear that and I'm,
I'm also sorry to hear that you're
paying a substantial,
I'm sorry to hear a general that you're
paying a substantial price for that.
Um,
I'm going to do what I can for what
that's worth to try to make sure that
people hear about this and that you're
not in it alone.
Because I think you guys are like
comedians.
You know,
your canaries in the coal mine and
whatever happens to you is going to
happen to a lot of other people if,
if it's allowed to happen to you so it
can't be allowed to happen to you.
That's what it looks like to me.
So thank you for your support.
All right guys.
Well,
thanks a lot for talking to me all.
Uh,
it was,
it was a stupidly interesting talking
with you,
but I just did not believe it's come to
this.
You know,
it's so ridiculous.
If you can't,
you couldn't invent this in a bad piece
of fiction.
And it's,
it's so sad that,
that this is the sort of thing that we
have to occupy ourselves when there's
serious work to be done.
All right,
well,
happy new year,
I suppose.
Hopefully this'll be a watershed year
and things will get more intelligent
from here on end.
Again,
I'm,
I'm sure,
hoping that'll be the case me to.
Thank you.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much for your time and
I'll let you know when this is all
coming online.
Okay,
bye.
Bye.